- HEY, SO WHAT'S NEW, GUYS?
WELCOME TO MY NEW LIFE HERE
IN THE RAP MASSAGE VAN,
WHERE I GIVE HOMELESS PEOPLE
FREE BUM RUBS.
- GOD, IT SMELLS LIKE, UH--
- IT'S LIKE--
- LIKE--
- UM--
- WELL, IT SMELLS LIKE YOU'RE
MASSAGING HOMELESS PEOPLE.
- YEAH, THAT'S--
- THAT'S EXACTLY WHAT IT SMELL--
THAT'S A GOOD WAY
TO DESCRIBE IT.
- ALL RIGHT, NOW LOOKIT, MAN,
WE GOT SOUP KITCHENS,
PLACES FOR HOMELESS PEOPLE
TO EAT.
BUT WE DON'T HAVE
MASSAGE KITCHENS,
PLACES FOR MASSAGES
TO GO DOWN ON HOMELESS PEOPLE.
- HEY, KARL,
I'M SORRY TO INTERRUPT,
BUT WE HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY
FOR YOU AND IT'S PRESSING.
- SHH!
- I'M SORRY.
KARL, WE'D LIKE TO YOU JOIN US
AT THE XZIBIT CONCERT.
INTERESTED?
- I'VE BEEN THINKING A LOT
ABOUT WHAT YOU GUYS SAID,
AND YOU'RE ABSOLUTELY RIGHT,
YOU KNOW.
TRYING TO FIND MY INNER PEACE.
AND RIGHT NOW,
I'VE KIND OF FOUND IT
IN THIS DUDE'S GIANT BACK.
I'M LOVIN' IT,
I'M LOVIN' IT.
SO, UH, I'M GONNA HAVE TO SAY
NA-NAY-NO, MY BROTHERS.
- NO, KARL.
COME ON, DUDE.
ALL YOU GOT TO DO IS PRETEND
LIKE YOU WERE HAVING SEX
WITH OUR CO-WORKER'S WIFE,
AND THEN HE'S PROBABLY
GONNA BEAT YOU UP,
JUST LIKE YOU WANTED.
- CAN MIKE COME?
- ♪ GET DOWN, TURN AROUND
SHOW ME WHAT YOU GOT ♪
♪ YOU A POW POW JUGGERNAUT
TAKE IT UP A NOTCH ♪
♪ ALL MY GUYS,
WOW, TAKE HIM OUT ♪
♪ LET ME TAKE A SHOT
- THERE'S YOUR BOY.
[rap music blaring
from headphones]
- I WANT YOU TO COME HERE
AND SEE THIS.
- WHO ARE YOU CALLING?
- IS THIS THE DUDE?
- AM I THE DUDE?
YEAH, I'M THE DUDE, MAN.
I'M THE DUDE, HOMEY.
I'M THE ONE
WHO'S BEEN GIVING YOUR WIFE
THE STINKY [bleep], MAN.
SO WHAT ARE YOU GONNA DO?
JUST PUNCH ME RIGHT HERE, MAN.
I WANNA BE YOUR BITCH.
- HIT HIM.
- YUP, MAKE HIM BLEED.
- WHOO!
- I WOULD LIKE TO KNOW WHAT
WAS SHE SAYING ABOUT ME?
- HOLD ON, WHAT YOU--
WHAT YOU SAY?
- I SAID,
WHAT WAS SHE SAYING ABOUT ME?
- WHAT WAS SHE SAYING ABOUT YOU?
UH...
OH, DUDE, SHE WAS SAYING THAT
YOU HAVE A TINY LITTLE DICK.
ALL RIGHT,
LIKE A TOOTSIE ROLL, MAN.
WHILE I HAVE
THE CHARLESTON CHEW,
THE KING-SIZED VERSION,
AND YOU KNOW YOUR BITCH
HAS A SWEET TOOTH.
all: OH!
- HE'S GOT HIM!
- YEAH! WHAT'S UP, NOW?
HIT ME. HIT ME, MAN.
- I'M MORE REFERRING
TO HER EMOTIONAL NEEDS.
- EMO--NO, THERE'S NOTHING
EMOTIONAL ABOUT IT, MAN.
YOU DON'T GET IT.
YOU CAN'T "F" RIGHT,
AND I GAVE HER
THE DUNKING DONUT,
AND THEN I
HAD THAT BITCH DOING
CIRQUE DU SOLEIL [bleep]
ALL OVER THE ROOM.
MAN, SHE CREAMED HER PANTIES
FOR ME.
- OH!
- GOD DAMN IT!
- AND GUESS WHAT
SHE CALLED ME, MAN.
SHE CALLED ME THE KING.
I'M KING KARL.
SAY IT, MIKE.
- HE THE KING.
- I'M--SAY IT, MIKE.
- HE'S THE KING!
- ONE MORE TIME, MIKE.
- HE THE KING!
- I'M THE KING, MAN.
AND GUESS WHAT.
YOU JUST THE PRINCE, MAN.
YOU PRINCE "MONTED."
"MONTED," YOU A BITCH.
OKAY? AND THAT BABY
IN YOUR WIFE'S STOMACH?
GUESS WHAT, MAN.
- TOO FAR.
- THAT'S MINE, DUDE.
SORRY, BUT YOU'RE NOT A DADDY.
YOU'RE NOT A DADDY.
NOW HIT ME, MAN.
- YOU KNOW WHAT?
I'M GLAD YOU HERE,
'CAUSE I WANT YOU TO SEE THIS.
- COME ON, MAN. YOU GET FIRST.
YOU GET NUMBER ONE.
COME ON, TED.
- UGH!
- OH!
- HELL, YEAH, BITCH.
- OKAY.
- YUP, YOU GOT HIM. THAT'S IT.
- GOOD TO GO.
- OH! YEAH.
- LOOK WHAT YOU GOT ME DOING,
WOMAN!
LOOK WHAT YOU GOT ME DOING.
- [laughing]
- OH, THAT'S GONNA BRUISE.
- TEZ, STOP IT! STOP IT!
- [laughing]
- I WISH I WAS DEAD!
GIVE THAT--OH! OH!
- KARL, YOU KNOW--
- KARL! WAIT!
TEZ, I'M THE CHEATER.
- WHAT?
[groans]
- OH, OKAY.
- [laughs]
OH, JESUS.
THIS IS A DILDO.
THAT'S A DILDO, GUYS.
OH, GROSS, MAN.